when it comes to Legal immigration would
president Rama Swami restrict it expand
it or keep it about the same so on
illegal immigration I'm a hardliner I
believe in the use of the U.S military
to protect our border it's a shame that
that's a controversial idea that using
our military to protect our border is
actually the most controversial use of
our military when in fact using it to
protect somebody else's borders somehow
perfectly fine so I'm you know what you
would call a hardliner on the issue of
illegal immigration on legal immigration
I think that we've gotten it wrong we do
we have a policy of accidental
immigration when I think we should have
a policy of intentional immigration we
have Lottery systems for H-1B visas I
mean this makes no sense why on Earth
would you want to leave it to a lottery
when you could actually just pick the
best ones to actually come best ones as
measured by commitment to the country
likelihood of making contribution to the
country based on their track record and
even their educational economic position
in a different country so I believe in
meritocratic points-based immigration